you
[Music]
for me robotics is about figuring out
how to build machines that are going to
enable people to interact with the world
you know much more effectively through
machines through avatars in in ways they
just weren't possible previously 212 is
introduction to robotics how do we get
machines to move in a certain way move
to certain locations configurations or
generating specific forces in their
environment today is Tuesday so the
competition is in two days
the robots now should be capable of
driving autonomously to the points on
the board most of the mechanical stuff
should be built this year the
competition is called Pokemon robotics
challenge the task is to design a
machine that is capable of locating
pokemons in their environment and then
catch them and put them in storage they
need to design an arm that is going to
grab these pokemons this is just a sort
of Gerber's they're made of acrylic and
it's mated to these gears that when they
open and close also actuate the
mandibles as well
so you can go and like grab things all
of this involves this autonomous
navigation avoiding obstacles and then
using vision to identify you know where
they are and then position the robot in
an appropriate way in front of these
bins
the thing that seems to be happening
right now is just kind of like jiggling
back and forth that's because it's
trying to get to a point but the
accuracy of the encoders is kind of off
so it kind of like overshoots and
undershoots they use this kind of a
filter of all this data to figure out
where it's located the only problem is
it's like very jumpy because it has so
many different data points that it's
just like trying to smooth everything
out and it's not quite there we've added
April tags these are like landmarks
because those are at the very very
specific locations they know the
coordinates of those tags
it helps robots to orient yourself when
sees one it do some kind of calculation
and then it will know where exactly it
is based on its view angle of this a
porter as well as the a protected
position which is known when the camera
sees these tags
since the Kinect has a death sensor it
can figure out how far am i from a tag
and if you know how far you are from a
tag you can figure out how far you are
from the reference point this is a
reference point right here so we're
referring to the bottom left corner of
the arena and so this April tag zero
right here is this tag on the screen put
this in front of the camera you'll
notice that is kind of like showing that
there's a robot right in front of that
tag it's looking straight at that
right now we're working on the
mechanical assembly so ours relies on
like a sweeper and a basket if we need
more experience than this we're trying
to collect all the Pokemon on it's
getting at the very end this Rack will
move up and then we'll swing right down
and everything else the seeker is
supposed to just go to Pokemon and sweep
it back and push it onto a platform and
then after we collect all of the Pokemon
on the platform we're gonna have another
mechanism that erases it and while
raising it the platforms and it tilts
and everything is gonna slide into the
basket so we hope with a lot of luck a
lot of other designs rely on like a
mechanical gripper and we're trying to
like alleviate some like errors everyone
comes up with a different strategy
that's part of the beauty of the design
process there's really no substitute for
a well-tested robot so the more time
that they can put on the ground I think
the better off their team will be our
navigation and trajectory planning we're
all done like within like maybe the past
two or three days as competition day is
coming I feel like everything's actually
falling together rather than falling
apart
this is it right this is the moment that
we've been waiting for this is the
competition for 2:12 but I really see it
as a celebration the students have
worked very very hard for more than 10
weeks you know to get to where they are
today it's off to a great start
currently using both odometry and April
tags to navigate unfortunately we've
lost about a fur coat so it's kind of a
sad letdown so we just couldn't stay up
and pull an all-nighter I'm trying to
figure it out
it tries to go to a waypoint that's
slightly in front of this April tag and
then basically checks to see how well it
does and based on the error in the
horizontal position it moves the arm and
tries to grasp the Pidgey which it did
successfully and now the arm should
deploy and release Pikachu into the tote
this challenge itself is actually within
the bar really high
not like some mediocre job through after
robots to do just kind of go for years
close you might get it come on speedy Oh
so he's got the right idea he knows
where he's going but he just sometimes
he's a little clumsy with his reach does
it sense whether it has it or not ever
doesn't know we don't have any force
sensors on there so he does the same
thing regardless thinks it has it sounds
tough to watch right there what could
have been many students say is a very
fun process because we are teaching the
state of the art of the industrial
framework so that's not only fun but
also very useful if they want to develop
robots for real world I don't know why
the April tact is so small and everyone
complained that are very noisy but the
despite that the one team did it a very
reliable job so this award the
navigation is going to team Charizard
come over here it would a lot better
than we thought it was going to a robot
definitely had its best day today
[Applause]